joining me right here on the rich eisen
show is uh one of my
my favorite people i i did nfl total
access with this man more than any other
human being on the planet
he's a pro football hall of famer he's
also an outstanding broadcaster colin
gaines for
our friends at westwood one and uh we
want to talk about his uh football
foundation as well hope through
football.org
uh he is rod woodson how are you rod
what's going on my brother how are you
doing what's going on
i'm doing good i can't complain i'm
better than i should be right that's
what we all say
and i mean pandemic has kind of made
everybody kind of
stir crazy but i think the silver lining
is
friends and family means more than we
thought it should
i love that rod that is a good point
that is an absolutely good point and so
and
and you're a grandpa right rod you're
you're grandpa rod right i
am i am i am a grumpy grandpa now
so i used to be a i used to be a grumpy
husband and father
but now i'm a husband husband father
and grandpa now uh this is how i i know
you right
um because i've i've i've heard so many
stories from you
uh i'm trying to remember the player
that made you the grumpiest
playing against him was webster
slaughter is that a correct
memory uh pulled by me that is
absolutely you're absolutely correct
and we've got multiple fights we got
kicked
because he talked a lot and i wasn't a
real talker but he got under my skin a
couple times and
i told him not to say one more i said
you said anything else to me
i'm gonna let you know he said something
after one of the plays and i just hit
him
and you know three days later
uh on wednesday i got a fedex package uh
envelope on my on my in my locker
and i got fined and i was like okay
that's the last time i'm doing a punch
in the game
so that was it that was it so it was a
money thing
i thought i threw a couple more punches
but
they were low key punches what does that
mean what do you mean but what are you
talking about what do you mean low-key
no people weren't looking kind of like
walking away just kind of throwing while
you're walking away
but i just left one big movement see now
i wasn't even planning on bringing this
up with you but since you mentioned you
you're grumpy um and so i i just
remember you told that story to us once
and we thought like webster
slaughter that was was that was that a a
a division rivalry thing too
also could it have been i think so
because you know when i first got to
pittsburgh it was a central
right so the only afc central and we the
steelers weren't the best team in the in
the central so
i mean cleveland was good cincinnati was
good
the steelers were down houston oilers
were a pretty good football team
and we were a young up-and-coming team
and now the last five years under chuck
noll
and he would get under my skin at on on
those games that we had to play twice a
year
and every single time that i you know
and there's it happens all the time on a
show like this one
where people are like complaining about
a call and an nba game
an nhl playoff game the nfl i always use
the phrase that you said chuck knoll
would warn you guys about before playing
every game
about playing better than the refs ref
and that was that i say that every
single time you told me that story also
on the set of total axes one day yeah i
mean you got you got to
outplay how the ralph's run and then i
mean i'm here
when i played i used to go to the you
know the field judge in the back judge
and i say you know how are you gonna let
us play you gonna let us hold today
they said laughing you know maybe i get
away with a couple holes they like
look at me with a straight face and go
no then i know i gotta play a little bit
cleaner
so you know but you do after you do
have to outplay how they call the game
that day
because they don't call the games
consistently throughout the whole year
so you got to figure it out as a player
how they're calling games if they're if
they're calling it tighter
then you got to kind of rain things in
if they kind of let them loose a little
bit
then you can kind of be you know kind of
you know go after and
do some of those penalties hopefully you
don't get those flag storm on you rod
woodson here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about the here and now what
do you think went down in that room
with uh art rooney ii and ben when they
talked about
moving forward here is it really only
about money what what
what what is going on in your old roost
well pittsburgh i mean i i think it i
think it is
i think ben wants to be there uh yeah
i think the rooneys have made a
concerted effort
uh now to keep their older players
uh you know back when i played they kind
of you know ten years it was a kind of
like a ten year limit with the steelers
and then once you get 10 it was kind of
let everybody go uh
now they do make a concerted effort to
keep their best players
i think ben wants to be there i think
ben made a huge difference in what they
did
last year on the football field
obviously they still need some more
pieces to the puzzle but
if they can get ben back for the right
amount of money and ben already said
that
he's willing to take a pay cut to come
back
and i i think the steelers would be
foolish not to have him there because
they don't have a
they don't have the future backup
quarterback sitting in that
building right now in pittsburgh so i
think
bring ben back get some you know
if they can get juju back or not you
know get some more speed at the
receiving core
and find a playmaker at the running back
position and
upgrade that offensive line i think they
they got a pretty solid football team
well i got to tell you man those last
two
uh points that you made right there is
what's crucial because
uh you saw what happened pretty much
from thanksgiving on
is every defense was sitting on in on
the short routes everyone was sitting on
that because they weren't afraid at all
of a running back coming out of that
backfield
no matter if it was conor or snell or
anybody it just wasn't even
any it wasn't even the thought process
of anybody getting behind them
or anybody coming from in front of them
it was just like just sit on those short
routes and i don't know if big ben
should be held accountable for that
or not but that it was a disaster it's
just i
i think you know i i think obviously you
know randy the
um often the coordinator he took
responsibility so they let him go
um and you know hopefully the new
philosophy
is to mix it up you can't be one
sided football team in the national
football league it'd be it
be it all short game be it all long
balls just being a running game we're
all passing so i i think
you have to be able to make defensive uh
defensive players and defensive
coordinators
play on their heels and if they can do
that then you can win some of those
games
rod woodson here on the rich eisen show
and i know that's your job to get in the
head of a
of a quarterback um and so i'm wondering
if
you can help me or what do you think
goes on in the minds of every
quarterback that's playing in the nfl
right now knowing that you know for the
last few years it was like okay
it's possible for me to catch brady i
can do that that
it's possible for me in my career to
walk away with as many rings as montana
and as many rings as brad shaw and
and i can you know get in the realm of
brady if not maybe catch him that's gone
now i mean that's toast it's over
it's that's what what must that feel
like to these
quarters i mean rich the only player
in the national football league playing
right now young enough
that maybe has that hope is patrick
holmes
i mean they he's young he they've been
there
most of the players on that roster
are under contract um so they have the
bulk and the core
of that football team together they
still eb hasn't got a job so they still
have the coaching
staff intact so i mean if anybody in the
league can do it which
brady made it harder obviously right he
definitely did that
um it could be fat from homes i mean he
could be the one to get there but
obviously somehow someway
andy would have to just keep bringing in
different players
um and they keep winning somehow some
way it just what brady did
in his career especially in new england
when he
had probably the least amount of talent
at the receiving core in the running
back position
and to keep winning that way and then
leave there
go to a new franchise learn the language
for the first half of the year because
they didn't have all season
and from the second half of the year on
they were just dominant uh in the
running game and the passing attack he
had a great feel for it and bruce
aaron's let
brady be brady and they won a super bowl
because of that so what he did you know
in this one year being a champ was just
incredible i i never said he was the
best quarterback but
um talent wise and he's not but he is
the best quarterback to ever play in the
national football league well i mean
it's incredible rod i mean your your
your career
and i i'll say it for you because you're
very humble man i mean
you're one of the greatest ever to lace
it up at your position
you're one of the greatest football
players ever and you have the
the resume to back it up in terms of you
know all century team and things of that
nature
um and so put it all together and you
played for one of the most
decorated franchises ever you you come
back from a knee injury in a super bowl
point to your knee as a matter of fact
in that super bowl but you didn't come
up on the winning end you
you got your ring with another
organization and you played in others
you know how
you were in one um and got you know
blown out because of a game plan change
i believe the night before
uh with the raiders you know and so put
it all together
you know how tough it is brady's had
he's won seven rod
it's insane when you think about it it's
crazy it's
crazy and he is i mean
when you when you take when you talk
about just pure
accomplishments of what he did and it's
not all brady
obviously but you know this is a team
sport but for him to win
seven and you know six in new england
he he goes to tampa and everybody was
questioning
why would you pick tampa you know yeah
they got some players here and there but
why tampa they're not going to be that
team and
the first part of the year it looked
like that but then once
brady figured it out once bruce aaron's
figured it out once brady figured out
what all his
weapons were and what they could do and
what they couldn't do
and that defense i mean that offense was
just one point
and you just have to take your hat off
to a guy like that who
can you know we had this question
at the beginning of the year that okay
who takes more credit should be
bill belichick or tom brady
everybody's asked that question and
unfortunately
it's looking like it was tom brady even
though bill belichick
should get a lot of that same uh
accolades
because they they went under his watch i
mean he's one of the best coaches
ever to coach in the national football
league obviously
uh but tom brady you know coaches have
schemes but tom brady he turns those
schemes in the reality
and he you know that little sixth you
know when he got drafted in the sixth
round that ship
stayed on his shoulder throughout his
whole career and it's amazing how
great a player he still is later in his
career
rod woodson pro football hall of famer
here on the rich eisen show at
rodwoodson26
on twitter which is how i saw you know
your
video yesterday about your foundation um
you tweeted at me and a bunch of other
uh folks on twitter and i just called
you up or texted you i'm like let's
let's chit chat about it
hope through football at hope through
football.org i give you the floor on
what this is and how people can get
involved
right yeah i mean it's you know rich i'm
a grassroots football guy it was great
being on tv especially with you
and it's still great calling games for
westwood one uh um
you know i love howard dinner off the
gentleman who runs it
um but helping kids practice or helping
our youth practice excellence through
football
everything i have in my life i got
through football and to give that back
to these kids
uh and really what we're trying to do
rich
is to get their get them to change their
mindset of i can i will
um we are what we repeatedly do uh
therefore excellence is not an act it's
a habit
so we're trying to get kids to believe
in what they see in the mirror the
person they see in the mirror
and the one thing i really like rich
that we do with
our group because we do bring we bring a
speed clinic coach with us
we have a weight coach comes with us and
helps with nutritionist
comes with us we have a recruiter that
comes with our group
but the biggest thing i really like that
we do is that we talk about concussion
and mental health
with the youth and i think that's really
important especially
through the pandemic we've seen more
kids take their lives
because of being maybe just wrapped up
in the house i'm not really sure
um but we do bring that to light and
we're telling kids that it's okay
to want help just because you want help
doesn't mean you're weak
i think people take that for a misnomer
um so we're you know we want to make
sure that we definitely talk about that
with our youth players
and then educate the parents on what
concussions really are and how that can
affect
the kids future so but my foundation is
i just want to
go out there help the kids um
anybody that wants to help us can go to
hopethroughfootball.org
we have 16 camps this year
we have 10 in the u.s six
internationally
um and you know we're but we're
definitely doing it our first camp is
going to be in houston texas
uh may 30th excuse me april 30th through
may 2nd
and that'll be something that you can go
donate and find out how you can
um how you can avail yourself of all the
the processes
of uh of hope through football at
hopethroughfootball.org
and um creating leaders on and off the
field on that'll be great in houston i
i hope um you get a commitment from
desean watson
uh better than the texans potentially
can these days
i i gotta track his number down so i
don't know
but uh i would say ask the texans for it
but i don't know if he's told him to
lose it
you know i don't know you see what i'm
saying yeah i don't i don't think
i don't think he gave it to david culler
yet so
do you like colleen i'm sure you must
know kelly you must know him through all
the years right
kelly started in pittsburgh way back in
the day back in 1997 i think that was
his first year in the league
um so david kelly cut his teeth in
pittsburgh which a lot of the uh
seems like a lot of coaches do now that
are throughout the years
but uh you know but i i'm i'm hoping
that
david culley gets his due and you know
if they don't keep desean watson
um you know and then david kelly takes
that job
well he took the job because he has
deshaun watson as his quarterback
and you know not having him at the
forefront of what that franchise is
jj's gone he's an arizona cardinal now
so
who's the next person everybody's
looking to it's deshawn watson
and you know i would hope that somehow
they can work it out i don't think that
desean wants to work it out
um so it's going to be interesting to
see what their stance is going to be
moving forward yeah i know but
why not get david collie a young
quarterback from a team that
that will take watson off their hands
and replenish all the draft choices for
the new general manager nick casario
that the owner obviously thought
was the proper combination of coach and
and general manager and let him build
from scratch right there let him build
his his
why have a hold out situation you know
for for the coach that just makes
no sense to me uh that's gonna
that's gonna be between the owner and
the the president of the club
and you know do they do they let
the players make the decision for
themselves so that's the question
right so you know he did sign a contract
a couple years ago
uh you know he's unhappy with the way
direction that's got franchises gone the
last couple years
uh he wants out i mean obviously jj you
know he wanted out too
because he saw the same kind of writing
on the wall
um now the owner has to make a decision
is he gonna let
every player out when they just because
they're uh unhappy
on the decisions that the franchise
making if they don't
that they do then they will trading if
they don't
and they feel that we're gonna make our
decisions even a lot of players probably
won't like it but we're not gonna let
them just
out because they want out so it's going
to be interesting to see how they work
it out
but i'm with you rich i'm with you he
doesn't want to be there
you know you're going to get some really
good draft picks
future draft picks you know for your
franchise and try to
hold from that now you're not going to
get another desean watson
in that draft but maybe you can get
other positions and you
you just get a well-rounded team and you
build a culture
of winning and then hopefully they could
change the
you know the mindset of what houston
texan looks like our player looks like
in the near future maybe you should tell
desean watson while he's holding out he
should just go run track in berlin like
a
10th overall pick of the 1987 draft once
did
who was that person holding out on the
steelers back in the
next season that would remember though
they had 87 they had a they had a
holdout
they had a hold out i mean you know they
had a strike so you know
it didn't come back i mean the scabs or
the
leftovers what they call them those guys
were playing
but uh you know the season didn't really
start till probably what week seven or
week or
six something like that with the regular
players and is that when you were
running traffic rich i was a 21 year old
knucklehead kid from purdue
they got to go run and my first race was
in
nice france and going to all those
different countries and running in the
european circuit
was just a tremendous thing for a young
kid out of indiana
see i have fun too i've spent too much
time with you rod i know your whole
story
you know i know your entire story i know
too much i know too much
i appreciate you coming on and sharing
though here appreciate it
you're the best no but i appreciate you
let me use your platform
um but anybody out there listening who
wants to help out they can go to hope
through football.org
and they can donate and they can reach
out to
rod at hope through football.org also
and if they want to be a partner with us
in any capacity
we're looking for that too anytime rod
let's get you back on and we'll promote
this again we'll keep hitting it uh best
to your family you'll be
you be well all right you're the best i
appreciate it brother thank you take
care you gotta hope
through football.org you can and it's a
hope
t-h-r-o-u-g-h not the shortening of the
word through
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here